Why was I not able to access some Zoom calls this last weekend?
Last week's Zoom call wasn't up until last night because I actually take that back. So
last week's Zoom call was up right after the Zoom call.
For a couple days and then we had an issue with our video site. So our video site got hacked again.
And sometimes you swear it's you to try to hack our video site because they don't want our videos
getting out there, but who knows them getting a little bit conspiratorial there. But our video
site was down and then it it when we had to reset it to a dust and went into reset it he had to
reset it back in time prior to that Zoom call being up so that we didn't realize that that Zoom
call that was deleted. So last week's Zoom call didn't get up till last night so I apologize
that because he had to work over the weekend to try to get our website our video site back up.
So that was a little bit of a hassle and that that threw off a lot of the Zoom call.
A lot of the other videos of the site were not coming up and we're coming up all
wonky so that's what the issue with that was now that's corrected so you can see last week's
Zoom call up there. If you ever go to our video site and you see videos that are coming up real
wonky or goofy or something's not coming up please send us a message either email us or
send a message through the member site that that's happening because you know we're not on it
every day so the times that it's got hacked several times and we may not catch it for several days
until somebody tells us so you could tell us we should do that. So that's why that video of our last
little video wasn't accessible. I'll be a apologize for that so